[Music]
guffies guies and they're kind of like
flat like dead de like instead of no
that sounds that sounds like
a guys sorry to interrupt man but uh
yeah Sam from HR needs to see you guys
so for what you just got to I don't know
it sounds Ser It's s from HR just go
just well I I don't think I doubt it
that that don't work can
eat all right gentlemen take a seat uh
Stephen I said take a seat I I know your
name's on the show in the front of the
building but you can at least take a
seat
right take us oh for
s
okay thank you gentlemen thank you for
joining me this afternoon um reason
you're here here is I've been getting a
ton of complaints all right what's all
this about Ben yeah what's all this then
Sammy boy oh that's Cockney it's a good
region it's Sam's favorite kind of knee
fist B oh that reminds me if you should
do a sketch called Schindler's fist guys
that's not appropriate get it yes I get
it but the reason you're here isn't
because of your inappropriate no all
right what do you know about boo it's
Irish the accents they need to stop I
uh
[Music]
p
hey relax
essay hey holes need just relax relax
[Music]
[Applause]
mate Mr Patrick Bet David how are you
sir very good and how do you run nine
companies that is something that right
away on its face just you know sounds
shocking I watch Jerry Maguire literally
after Jerry Maguire I write a 16 page
you know what we ought to do to take
this company to the next level with
nobody responds back if you don't value
these ideas maybe I go do it myself 3
months later I resigned I start own
company PHP agency with 66 agents and we
grew that from 66 to 45,000 agents it
was exciting it was great
more and more and more I got into it I
said I want to talk about this stuff so
then we separated by tment with PD
podcast we started that in a mo why do
it what made you say Okay I want to take
this risk and that's a lot of work you
don't trust mainstream media I'm willing
to pay the price because I'm going to go
out there and do something big prove the
people that believed in me right and
prove the people that doubted me wrong
and then eventually my dreams are going
to become a
reality I love it I love every minute of
it
[Music]
[Applause]
what I
know got
the
[Music]
okay let me put it to you that way that
60% 90% complete
right I don't know uh that'll be
tomorrow I'll sit down and Ash Wednesday
on an actual Wednesday with uh I was
about to say Dan Bonino with Patrick Bet
David yes some people call him pbd and
then on Thursday we're going to have a
live dual stream event I'll be doing Dan
Bonino show nice yeah that uh the Deo
has his own program he's done well for
himself and then uh I will be streaming
here but we'll be doing it all from the
mug Club Studios yeah noce that I just
dropped it oh wow you I just dropped it
down bino height oh come on I think he's
tall he's a fairly tall guy yeah I I
I've never spent time with him in person
anyways that's going to be I didn't
introduce you yet silence let me put it
you that way you have to close your mom
okay that's not bad so uh now let's run
down uh the stories here really quickly
what we'll be getting to today uh San
Francisco has decided that they're
finally going to clean up the act for
xingping be nice if they did it for the
citizens of San Francisco you know what
even just the people of Oakland uh we're
also going to be showing you some Hamas
child propaganda cartoons real they're
equivalent to Sesame Street just in case
you weren't fully aware of evil as well
as hilarity in the world um we'll be
showing it to you and spoiler alert your
kids should not actually be watching
this unless you want to train them to uh
kill the
udans I don't know if I can laugh these
are real you can laugh it's these are
actual shows for the children uh and
then we're also going to get into look
you've been hearing a lot about this how
we have a rise in anti-Semitism and
islamophobia M right there's a task
force to deal with islamophobia take a
guess which one of those is actually
kind of true and uh comment below to
what degree have you seen you know
anti-Semitism impact your community and
do you think it's a term that's may be
thrown around too much uh nowadays um I
think that there are anti-semites for
sure I think that a lot of islamists are
definitely anti-semitic I don't think
that people who have you know legitimate
grievances with for example the
government of Israel and I'm not talking
about the conflict but it's not
necessarily A Bastion of of of Freedom
uh and conservatism either so um I I
want to be clear when I say
anti-Semitism I mean like beating up
people because they're Jewish yeah like
chanting gas the Jews this happened in
Australia I didn't chant that they to be
fair they were saying that they were
funny they were saying the Jews are a
real gas I don't think so context
matters but also probably bad with all
the Aboriginal schas all right number
two Captain Morgan how are you sir I am
doing well how are you I'm fine next's a
little bit better a little bit better I
think I tweaked my shoulder as well but
no one cares about that when you hear
this you know him you love him Sunday
November 19th he'll be at Bricktown
comedy club in Tulsa Oklahoma you can
see his other dates on his Instagram
Josh firin how are you sir I am good I'm
doing good man I'm I'm still a little uh
a little hung over for my uh barbecue
last night did a barbecue last night I
overate barbecue last night oh really oh
yeah at MSG yeah I hope so with the
Chinese restaurants when you say don't
put an MSG they put it in anyway it's
like yeah no one else is claiming they
don't have MSG yeah I know sounds
suspicious I had a guy lay it out for me
in a Chinese restaurant in Michigan
where he goes he goes you know people
say and he had like aild Asian accent so
I can't do it with that he goes you know
people say MSG you ever you ever you
ever eat lays so goes lay more MSG in
lays than your whole meal I don't know
if that's true go to lays go to lays
yeah go to go to go to Pringle say no
MSG I don't know if I believe that I
don't know if I believe him but
yeah exactly that and sugar they just
put it all in their sauces anyway sounds
like propaganda from lucky noodle he was
really upset about it like he was on a
campaign to educate us speaking of
campaigns uh Megan rapos is over
yeah her career ended
unceremoniously God I thought she was
running for office no oh I guarantee you
she will at some point uh she ended her
career on and she was look she was
injured uh into her uh I guess 3 minutes
into her final into her final match and
here's the thing you know she could have
been gracious and instead she took the
opportunity which look comment below it
surprises me I kind of thought one of
the perks with lesbians is they wouldn't
be as
Naggy but I don't know that's my
Straight ignorant privilege you need a
nag with every old
bag that's what I always say that's her
that was her nickname in uh College was
glad bag
so was actually sad sad
bag so uh she took the opportunity
rather than to you know kind of go
through her career thank everyone who
made it possible uh to tell you that
this means there's no God yeah I thought
about a little bit I mean you know I'm
not a religious person or anything and
if there was a god like this is proof
that there isn't up um so yeah it
just it's just fued up you guys like
just minutes
in so bad yes good no
way yeah it's funny because sometimes I
feel like there's no God when I watch
soccer but she here the whole planet
likes it exactly someone there be a
flood I don't know how it counts with
lesbians if it's 2 by two but I really I
have a problem one I have a problem the
blue hairs aren't mating two pairs of
scissors
you need four blades for as long as
they're practicing as long as they're
practicing as long as they're safety
scissors
now this is what you can expect today uh
she actually what really bothered me to
get serious for a second is she caused a
a crisis in faith for me because I
thought for sure um you know even God
can't stand her and then he came through
I mean you know I'm not a religious
person or anything and if there was a
god like this is proof that there isn't
[Laughter]
that's a great effect guys salt for
people don't know the how arrogant the
holy book uh by the way if we haven't
hit this yet do we have someone out
there doing this today I realize because
someone is sick the YouTube dump button
if at some point you see this while
watching on YouTube we'll get
it that means head on over to rumble and
I realize the person usually does it as
sick today so that was not a good lead
in
yeah the timing on the dump button was
perfect though is it is it true am I hey
comment below I'm hearing that other
people are starting to do a YouTube dump
button me too I've heard is that true
guys comment below because hey I mean
I'm not going to say they ripped it off
I'm glad I hope more people are doing
that because I want to watch YouTube die
figuratively okay like Megan's career
yes figuratively now
um but she's Rich so who cares oh my
gosh we're not done with this entitled
broad yet no we are not oh my gosh he's
going to be like Jimmy Carter you're
taking someone who's entitled and now
you just put more time on their hands I
know she blew out her Achilles 3 minutes
in oh no the
horror I'm sorry let's not laugh at her
Misfortune I'm not laughing at her
Misfortune I'm laughing at the fact that
she thinks because her last game was
ended early that there must not be a God
on the
play there can be no God with this kind
of way of going how about missing the
last penalty kick of your career in the
Women's World Cup that one was funny too
which I don't understand I mean the the
size of the it's bigger than the studio
yeah it it happens it's rare there's
also a war going on at God's
house his old stomping grounds maybe
he's a little busy Megan have you
checked out my junior suite he's going
to help the a i airb and beat it for a
while I came back it's
this sorry I didn't pay attention to
your soccer career there's a couple
major Wars going on and famine and oh
you can't hit a 10 can around in the
streets of
wherever that's why is the most
practiced sport you have a tin can you
have an object that you can kick you can
play soccer okay don't let Mighty Ducks
2 fool you there are not a lot of people
in South Central LA playing full-on
roller hockey on a basketball court they
just can't afford time yeah she fair I
want to see her knuckle Puck no way way
all right speaking of uh I don't know
knuckling down San
Francisco I mean it's still a matter of
fist so in San Francisco uh so you know
San Francisco it sucks to begin with it
does right so we've covered this quite a
bit you know the homeless problems there
all of the drugs the poop in the streets
the good news is there's an app so you
can track where poop is most frequently
found in the streets it's just
everywhere it's just the app is just one
bit very little for poop like oh wow
that's where the poop is no that's where
there's not poop yeah
oh like Frogger it would look like it's
like like heat like a heat map like
you're using thermals it be like
predator looking into into a
volcano just everywhere it's like what
do you do so God now though they decided
to get their act together ahead of this
week's uh Asia Pacific economic
cooperation event MH yeah Apec is what
they call but I always say ape but I for
I didn't really know what it stood for
like as all the words and it still makes
very little sense no it doesn't just say
the Asians are coming the Asians are
coming so
orientals so now the city is working
overtime to clean up the streets well
that's fantastic look at that and this
uh includes everything from deep
cleaning the BART system to yes pressure
washing the uh poop off the streets of a
modern American city in western
civilization city leaders are making
sure the city shines tourism is our
business here in San Francisco and we
need to focus on making sure weeners is
that guy's
[Laughter]
business Street off ramp from the I80
Bart doubling down by deep cleaning
their stations overnight more often the
city had gotten a little bit dingy over
time scrubbing and power washing is
happening all over the city yeah the
bottom of my shoes look clean like it's
noticeable how few homeless encampments
there are on major thorough okay two
things two things having done a little
bit of like local news with Nashville
because I felt like they were owed one
with the manifesto they have to take it
seriously yeah man there's poop in the
bottom of my shoeses this man says his
shoes are cleaner now that the streets
have been hosed off they have to take it
seriously and the other thing is that
guy in the Fedora he thinks he looks way
cooler than he does like he thinks he
looks like Frank Sinatra but he looks
like a mascot at Red
Robin the city used to have a little
more class okay and you know what it
helps with the algorithm hit like if
you're glad to see baby steps less human
feces on the streets of the Golden City
guys are like I might look like a douche
but I Did It My
Way It Was a Very Good Year he's a
bottom he did it some other guy's
way he did it how he was
told he liked it so San Francisco
they've taken a lot of uh steps recently
just to be clear you know steps you
would think they would take on a
day-to-day basis they've just decided
it's like spring cleaning you have to do
that in classroom as a kid like do
spring cleaning it's just an excuse to
get kids like they make you clean the
gutters and everything like this is just
this is a gross violation of labor laws
spring cleaning for hobos in Francisco
so now they've decided they are going to
start taking steps for the Asians who
are visiting for xingping to help get
the homeless people off the street some
steps they've taken is they've shut down
some homeless encampments they've moved
some people off the streets they've
added 300 beds uh to their shelter
system overnight all of a sudden they
have capacity to add 300 beds to their
shelter system when they didn't before
well there's only two more sleep till
shiing ping oh so the San Francisco da
also started a new program called all
hands on deck to arrest fentanyl
dealers sailor boys from San
Francisco by the way so it's a real
program all the references are available
at L cr.com all hands on deck to now
start arresting fentanyl dealers not to
be confused by the way with their
holiday program all hands on deck the
halls during which Black Santa delivers
Naran to all the good junky boys and
girls of the world so that's
a he's throwing it at him
head will be
ringing you'll be Frozen in
Time I Saw Mommy smoking with Santa
Claus underneath the old Golden Gate
Bridge last
night it's a song about infidelity I
don't like it
now when I was a kid I would get mad
like Mom's cheat that cheating and
my dad didn't want to
Santa he's like yeah I mean come on now
one night a year
yeah so um what uh San Francisco refused
to do and this is look this is the point
here is it funny sure but this is what
the left do it's all about keeping up
appearances right when they talk about
communism Marxism so it's beautiful in
theory right Joe Biden Biden omics they
want to put they want to put a nice
front on a nice storefront you go in and
you realize it's just like I'm trying to
think what would be uh it's it's it's
like uh it's like Marshalls
mhm
so just I don't know I trying to think
it's like Talbots as a as a straight
young male I have no interest in going
to tets but they want to put a nice face
on it they're not actually interested in
improving uh the quality of life for the
residents so now what they've refused to
do for years for the residents of San
Francisco they have done in a matter of
days or at most weeks for xingping I
know folks say oh they're just cleaning
up this place cuz all those fancy
leaders are coming into town um that's
true because it's
true don't forget it now to be fair
context he went on to clarify what it
was that he meant anytime you put on an
event by definition you know you have
people over your house you're going to
clean up the house ah got it that's
that's more that's that's more clarity I
think so the people who live in the
house just living squalor yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah everything sucks and then
so San Francisco is basically Pacific
Heights it's a hoarders house yeah it's
a very underrated film by the way you
guys can comment below if you remember
the razor blade thing that Michael Keon
does it was nice so they're cleaning up
for China and Russia and by the way the
people of China obviously this is
different the CCP the people of China
would not be able to discern the
difference I mean they cook in in they
cook street food and sewage very often
but they clean up for the royalty for
the oligarchs so you have she Biden
they're set to meet this Wednesday um
hey San Francisco at least it'll be
better for a couple of weeks now what I
hope the people of San Francisco and if
you're out there right now and you live
in San Francisco or the surrounding area
please comment below
contrast what you're living these next
couple of weeks versus what you've
experienced the last few years and then
what I want you to do is go back and see
what information was available hey were
there other people in this country
saying your city is a cesspool and
there's a way to improve it and you
ignore them this can be a learning
experience or or you can go right back
to the squal in which you lived earlier
and just put your head in the sand and
act as though that's normal because it's
multiculturalism so ahead of this
meeting too with she Shing ping um he
made sure that Gavin Nome he was the one
who requested it so you can actually I
don't give him credit wear very often
but credit wees do xingping is the
reason that San Francisco has been
cleaned up um he he he insured
it hello Kevin hi we all set we're all
set Mr president we've got we're all
looking forward to is there still poop
in the street no we've cleaned that up
so no poop no no poop no poop and no
homeless right no homeless what what
about all the all the
gay excuse me the the the guy the the
gay guy oh the gay guy he still the gay
well we remain open and what about
godilla I'm sorry what was that godilla
godilla G Godzilla Japan says no we
haven't had any reports of uh
Godzilla just call me back when you k a
gay they are not the most tolerant
people oh oh by the way this is
something else uh there's nothing more
to really add to that just you know San
Francisco is terrible and uh again I
just hope when people say hey we did the
best that we could when they talk about
Co no no you you aren't judged
historically by what information you
made available you're judged by what
other information was available at that
time was has there been information
available over the last half decade that
would have cleaned up San Francisco I
mean we've been talking about it uh the
governor of Texas has been talking about
it I believe the Governor of Oklahoma
City has been talking everyone has been
talking about it but they've done it
their way hey at a certain point results
matter yeah and not two or three weeks
worth of making the city look cool again
just you know maybe do something for the
the citizens that live there and pay the
taxes not just the visitors coming in
this is how you're going to end up with
another Dirty Harry punch some women in
the face that guy hey by the way this
just happened earlier unrelated but CNN
their news anchor uh uh Norm e he was on
the screen and he is a dead ringer for
the Muppet newsman did you guys see this
look at this come on oh my
gosh oh my gosh the crooked glasses and
all look at that I'm surprised he's not
just trying puns like oh the temperature
is dropping today and thermometer
falling oh no oh boy it's about as
believable I love it sorry it was just I
couldn't get my mind off of it uh it's
aside it's obsessing over for the last
hour so so now we're going to talk about
uh uh this is something I think is
pretty important a lot of people will
say and by the way I do understand and I
do hear that some people out there are
right to criticize some of the
exaggerated atrocities sometimes uh that
you hear from from the IDF it shouldn't
matter because we have seen footage of
women elderly and children slaughtered I
mean you have to be a real piece of
human trash to machine gun children but
the
idea that you know they've been beheaded
or uh put in ovens you've heard these a
lot of that is unconfirmed so I
understand that criticism but that
doesn't change the fact that Hamas
targeted women and children I think that
Americans need to whitewash it in their
minds because we live in a time or
certainly an area of the world we're not
really aware of of true evil we see it
every now and then um like you talk
about School shooters for example and
that happens and it's terrible and it's
evil Hamas is an entire Army of School
shooters executing children to be clear
now how does that happen how do you have
an entire Army of people you know 57% of
the Palestinian people support Hamas
knowing what they do yeah uh it starts
very young so I think this is important
for you to see it's disturbing uh it's
equal parts disturbing and hilarious
because if you don't laugh you know
they'll kill Jews
so yeah let me start with what was your
favorite cartoon as a child what lessons
did it teach okay now let's contrast
that with uh Hamas programming from 2007
to
2014 Hamas aired a children's TV show
called tomorrow's
Pioneers this is children's broadcasting
as produced by Hamas run television in
Gaza but don't be fooled by the colorful
scenery oh for a second it was of songs
and stories
the show serves up political ideology
disguised as cuddly animals to be fair
you're not alone not too many people
were fooled as seen by the 2.6 out of 10
on IMDb so I'm happy to tomorrow
Pioneers I love the
name so let me give you though who's
reviewing that like I love the ideology
but the production value is a little low
I just don't like bunnies very serious
I'm not a bunny guy rer so um to blown
off thumbs down
what so let me give you the timeline
there are few characters and we won't
have time to get to all of them so some
of this we'll do exclusively on mugclub
because it also gets even more shocking
it gets worse uh let me give you first
The Arc of little farer so
farer farer farer hates the West farer
is essentially a Jihad Mickey
Mouse
it's a gross violation of copyright law
it is yeah I mean I don't know where
YouTube is with their strikes on this
but you know we got we got struck for
doing a parody of The Cranberries you
know zombie so come on YouTube Just
uphold your own laws so uh let me show
you some videos here now you see how you
you you raise an entire generation of
people to hate an entire group of people
uh here's a clip of farer or far for I
don't care caught cheating in class and
hold on a second spoiler alert spoiler
alert it's the Jew's
[Music]
fault people listening on audio by the
way if you're and you can all listen on
Spotify Apple all those places Google
Stitcher uh you're going to have to
watch this
yeah I don't want to ruin it by reading
You by you know dubbing the subtitles
that's a real stretch I had to cheat
because the Jews destroyed my house
first I I thought he was cheating off of
a Jew which would have made sense that
made yeah a lot more sense but they
wouldn't be in class together stepen
so he said that Jews destroyed his house
that I couldn't find my notebooks and I
didn't want to cheat
yeah the Jew dog ate my homework oh so
you weren't paying attention in class
for the other three months leading up to
this test no
that's because I was thinking about the
Jews I don't like them Papa okay so it
gets worse it does it gets much worse in
a Children's Program far for he he was
was murdered mhm murdered by you guessed
it a
Jew who wants to steal this is for
children this is how you raise an entire
generation of people who then just
execute Jewish Women and Children evil
exists so he was martyred in this series
for children murdered by a Jew who
wanted to steal his land
the Jewish Banker
[Laughter]
Trope why is the
juice for Family
[Applause]
Matters
[Music]
fake Jew has an uppercut
on no that was like God that's is this
is all all the references are available
at lc.com you can click the link in the
description this is for children and in
case you're a bit of a cliffhanger there
in case you were wondering what happened
to far for after that spoiler alert um
he was old sand
yelled
now you know when you have people here
in the left and this is why
progressivism just for progressivism
sake it cannnot uh uh to man are we are
we still waiting on the the next things
coming up or do we have them I got them
okay good progressivism just for the
sake of progressivism you're just you're
moving in a direction you just say I'm
moving forward it doesn't matter if
you're moving into a thorn bush this is
why the left can talk about othering
people here in the United States yeah
and then support Hamas you just saw a
child child issue propaganda to other an
entire group of people that every single
Jew is a thief is a terorist is a
murderer this is what they show on their
PBS are you starting to get the picture
and if you think that's bad but that's
just one of the children shows true you
wouldn't believe what was left on The
Cutting Room
floor that's a bad one
yes and and don't foret don't don't
forget this
one yeah
piku go Pikachu Pik
Pikachu nothing
the lightning bolts and the Striking and
the Poke
balling all the training day with the
training training on the monkey bars you
can take it you go Monkey Bar no
no this is the worst uh program for
those who listen on audio every now and
then you know I didn't not try and file
it didn't make sense sometimes it does
not today so let me give you another uh
Arc this is a character nul ah so nul
the bee
uh
nul not another n it's nul another be
movie nah nul you think you are buddy a
Jew no not no no I kid don't say it's
nice to laugh no I'm just a Palestinian
child homeowner
yes how can you focus on your studies
when the Jews keep taking your houses
yeah he's like I have all these
properties and they keep taking
them so now now the bee filled in after
faur's martyrdom yeah the rabbit
replaces nul the bee who gets his fun
from tormenting cats and from throwing
stones at a caged lion but nul didn't
leave the show because of his naughty
Behavior the young viewers are told that
the cuddly bee died because the Israeli
Siege on Gaza prevented him from
reaching a hospital well that doesn't
even make what it doesn't even make
sense like yeah wouldn't it wouldn't
that be plus one for the Jews this this
nul for he likes abusing animals for
those he's like there's a cat I'm going
to kick it yeah and it's like he died
because of the Jews wouldn't kids be
like well you know he was kicking
animals for no reason kind of a jerk
he's kind of a dick little known fact uh
gazen children hate cats more than Jews
do they hate cats oh wow oh that makes
sense okay so nul died because of a
Jewish Siege on Gaza preventing him from
from going to a hospital as they told
you um because they have very poor
writing so we have now a scene uh uh
from nul's death for
[Music]
children ministering
CPR now
but they just ripped off my girl they
just instead of the B stings they just
put the b in the
casket
was this is so stupid suck his
honey so the kids who watched this they
grew up to be what you now see as Hamas
Fighters and of course they continue
with this kind of programming and I do
think it matters to say look there's a
conflict going on but the way that they
the way that they address their
opposition it's not lost to me that you
have plenty of Jews in Israel who
probably hate the people of Hamas who
probably revile them who probably do
Harbor hatred in their heart and I'm
sure that some of them you know a
Palestinian who maybe isn't an extremist
can do no right that's not law we're
talking about this as a matter of policy
and as a matter of programming to
children can you guys can you can you
come up can can can you see the
difference now at the same time these
Israeli children shows um they at the
very least sometimes are teaching kids
about friendship between Arabs and
[Music]
Jews
little boy looks like Natalie Portman it
does that's me in
Jew
by the way not that I want to be sued by
PBS for my former role as the brain but
uh the brain celebrated K Quanza so I'm
will to bet he was not a big fan of the
Jews no probably not it's quite the
stark contrast there yeah if you don't
know you can go watch the change my mind
Quan is not real was created by Ron
Everett who did Time in a Los Angeles
prison for beating women with soldering
irons and pouring bleach down their
throats but hey you know it's celebrated
by 1% of African-Americans and0 %
Africans so now you've seen the journeys
of far fur The Mouse and nul the be you
know and their demise unfortunately well
but if you want to see rest of power
Kings yes we was
Kings if you want to see their friends
ass sued the rabbit and Nur the teddy
bear um you'll need to join us on mug
Club later because I don't even know if
we can show that here on YouTube it just
it would all be YouTube dump button so
lit.com mugclub you'll get another 45
minutes to an hour of show Nick depalo
tonight Friday show you'll get Alex
Jones on Friday you get Brian Callen
every week you get the Hodge twins and
it's the only thing that keeps these uh
it's the only thing that keeps the
lights on here because we are not
sponsored by a foreign caliphate
now everything we got it I think so can
I one thing I I you say many things okay
many things uh I love the there's a good
point you said these kids were watching
in 2007 2008 and now they're military
age fighting men yeah and uh I just love
the idea of this guy going into battle
like this is for the f
Justice pigs nul is always with us he
will always be in my
heart as some shitty Phil Colin rip off
he'll be in my
heart in my heart it is like Tarzan you
know the one where he kills all the Jews
um I don't
think do you think it's just like still
have like Family Video and Blockbuster
in Palestine all
changed Family Video they just sell they
sell suicide videos oh the God no that
was very good The Godfather the one with
the Jew head in the bed right yes I know
if that's what I mean it was all right
Eight Crazy Nights is a different movie
yes it is yes it's just a blank
tape so this brings us to look uh
obviously you know we like to have a
laugh but the the whole narrative right
now that uh there's other siding stuff
and I'm not going to do that I try to be
very straightforward with you we all do
that we have our biases here yeah okay
you've heard now well at least this
narrative is what you've heard
throughout all the media is especially
with the task force created this white
house for islamophobia you've heard that
anti-Semitism is increasing and that
part is true we'll have some numbers
here for you but so is
islamophobia on college campuses
Nationwide Jewish and Muslim Students
worry the war overseas is fueling hate
here at home I do not feel safe and is
that true of all hate speech Muslims
Jews as targets it's true of
anti-Semitism and anti-muslim hatred as
the FBI has noted we are seeing an
increase in reported threats against
Faith communities particularly Jewish
Muslim and Arab communities and
institutions we've seen a horrific rise
of islamophobia Muslim and those
perceived uh to be Muslim have endured a
disproportionate uh number of hate
fueled attacks
and certainly President Biden
understands that many of our Muslim Arab
AR Arab Americans and Palestinian
American loved ones and neighbors are
worried about the hate being directed at
their communities okay so now you have a
task force right you have a task force
for islamophobia which I mean there's a
task remember when Obama he was when
there was a zar for everything yeah just
everything had a zar so let's go through
the claims because the truth matters
here's the claim that they're making
okay that both anti-Semitism and
islamophobia are way up all right here's
the truth
statistically anti-Semitism has
increased significantly and a huge
portion of that yep comes from uh the
Islamic world and it's increased far
more than islamophobia so from October
7th 2023 to today versus um the same
period last year as a comparison and
these sources just to be clear they have
to come from the ADL and care who are
clearly biased because we don't really
have these numbers yes they definitely
would be more left leaning by ADL
probably would register both of them
because you know hate crimes are catnip
to the ADL but care certainly has a dog
in this fight uh considering that they
have been recognized as an actual
terrorist organization I Believe by the
UAE if I'm not mistaken a few different
nations so anti-semitic hate crimes
meaning attack meaning attacks against
Jewish people have increased
388 then the claim is that anti-islamic
hate crimes have increased
216% okay so those are from the ADL and
care but here we have the FBI director
Chris Ray um saying that hate crimes are
disproportionately anti-semitic and then
we'll give you some of the those numbers
What proportion of these hate crimes has
been directed towards Muslims for
instance if 60% were towards Jews what
percent towards Muslims I I don't have
that percentage but it's it's obviously
quite a bit smaller than 60% by
definition but I think the point that I
was trying to make there which I really
think Americans need to understand is
how wildly
disproportionate if you could ever use a
word like proportionate in something
like this that is 2.4% of the American
public 60 % of religious-based hate
crimes this is a group that is has the
uh outrageous distinction of being
uniquely targeted and they need our help
so you have the care numbers and you
have the ADL numbers sort of more
internationally but these are now the
numbers from the FBI FBI 2022 stats is
quoting because that's the most recent
stats that he has it's closer to like
55% they're probably rounding up a
little bit and on the anti-islamic hate
crimes
7.7% yeah so I I think the focus here
should probably be on the anti-Semitic %
of hate crimes for 2.6% of the
population right that seems
disproportional to me well I think not
only is it disproportional but what
matters is who's committing the crime so
in other words if 55% of the uh
recipients of being walloped right hate
crimes are Jews well how many hate
crimes are they perpetrating I would
imagine not as many as the islamists you
know who make up 7.7% of the victims
they tend not to I would imagine that a
lot of the anti-semitic hate crimes are
being committed by islamists there are
far more Muslim Muslims just so you know
in the United States then there are
white supremacists it's not even
close so let's kind of look at this how
this is translated into the real world
um these are an you now have the
empirical let's go to the anecdotal
October 21st the Detroit synagogue
leader uh Samantha wool she was murdered
at her home yeah terrible story and
Detroit police said that this was not a
hate crime citing an untouched Israeli
flag at her house yeah literally this
woman was found dead on the sidewalk
they followed a blood trail she had been
stabbed several times early in the
morning after coming home from a wedding
and the police go in the house and I S I
kid you not the only reference to this
not being a hate crime and look you
can't just assume because this was a
Jewish leader that it was a hate crime
right but that's probably where you
start right especially certainly when
you're skipping you're skipping a hop
away from Dearborn yeah exactly right
with tensions as high they as they are
they're like oh hey guys hey guys that
flag right over there it's it's perfect
it's just it's left untouched that can't
be a hate crime yeah maybe it was just a
hate criminal uh in a hurry yeah or
maybe just a hate crime somebody who
hates Jews and but really respects the
flag yeah exactly it's a pretty flag
could it's a nice blue it is could be
they didn't have a lighter yeah that's
probably it could have been that they
were too busy practicing their stabbing
yeah they were very you
know sounds like hate anyway it does
sound like hate whether it's racial hate
or what and again I don't think when
we're talk murder doesn't need a
footnote we're just talking about using
the left standard anyway and in this
case I mean where where's Columbo when
you need okay hold on a second this is
this is a woman who's a leader of a
synagogue stabbed in her home skipping a
hop away from Dearborn where you've
heard the kind of rhetoric of course
from Rashida T and representatives there
I've spent quite a bit of time in
Dearborn if you're not aware of the
extremism that goes on there uh hamic
right outside of Detroit is the one
place I believe in the United States at
least at one point it was where you can
actually hear the Islamic call to prayer
across the municipality so it wouldn't
be hard if he did a little bit of
investigating then again we're still
talking about you know the police force
or sometimes the FBI who had no known
motive from the Nashville
shooter remember that that's why it
matter when people say why would you Rel
it's not about clicks it's about the
truth Hey would this help Jews in
Detroit or near Dearborn better equip
themselves to stay safe hey you know
what maybe Jewish Americans if they knew
that they were being targeted
disproportionately according to Ry
himself maybe more of them will become
Second Amendment supporters yeah right
it will dictate behavior and that will
dictate policy truth matters we can give
you another example November 6th there
was an elderly Jewish man and we're
going to show you just so you know a
clip we're not showing you a clip of the
man dying or um you know the attack uh
he was killed in La after an altercation
with an anti-israel
protester now the original NBC news
headline read man dies after hitting
head during Israel and Palestinian
rallies in California Jesus and this
pissed people off all across well then
the death was ruled uh homicide by the
vur county sheriff but we that's the the
thing about this is like you know we
talk about this all the time what did we
know and when did we know it right they
knew from the very moment because all of
the reports coming across on X and this
is where it first kind of broke like all
of those reports were that a a protester
clashed with this guy and attacked him
and he fell and hit his head as a result
of the attack yeah that is not a man
falling and hitting his head that is a
man being attacked and dying from the
attack yeah and they chose to cover it
that way because they're like ah we
don't we don't make it look like you
know a pro Palestine you know protester
just killed some guy because he hel held
up a sign that says you know I stand
with Israel whatever he had right that
that infuriates people because it's the
same thing that we discussed with white
black crime the other day right it's the
exact same thing playing out and they
could have just said it and been honest
and it would have been fine and by the
way I've experienced this yeah you know
not only being sucker punched at the
right to work rally that took place in
Lancing where they followed me to my car
and said we will kill you with a gun
they say it on camera right and the the
police had that yeah the police have the
gigabytes of all that the Lancing PD um
I also experienced it for example when
we had the transgender individual throw
a homeless man's pencil case lunchbox at
me if let's say that concuss me
guarantee you it wouldn't have been
reported because a lady sitting right
next to me who was a leftist said well
you look like you're fine the behavior
is excusable if they believe that the
person who performed said Behavior Uh is
oppressed that is progressivism that is
Marxism let me read it to you again man
dies after hitting head during Israel
and Palestinian rallies in California
they're trying really hard to be
dishonest shits yeah and right
underneath that pull that back up really
quickly because you want to know if I
know that they knew right underneath
witness said Paul Kessler was in a
confrontation with protesters Sunday
what
protesters what what would he as a
pro-israel person what what other
protesters were there was he fighting
with his own people and that's what
happened no you have it right there this
reads like it could be a Life Alert
bracelet commercial like I've fallen and
hit my head I'm build of
but they but they get but they cover the
story they want you to know they cover
the story it's there you ignored it cuz
it sounded like an old man having an
accident what a weird lie like that's
like oh man Tri and fall man dies after
committing suicide jumping from the 80th
floor of the World Trade Center right
yeah like oh well oh he committed
suicide really okay all right nice story
is there something more that we need to
well you know look we assume that the we
assume that the fall is what killed him
yeah well it's not so much the fall as
the sudden stop yeah yeah well know
inera terminal velocity they say I just
I really the F no it's true that look
this is the deception yeah and this is
why hey you know and thank you so much
for everyone who supports mug club that
you're the ones who made the Nashville
Manifesto happen and you can send your
tips if you have other stories like this
where you know the media has lied send
them to lwc tips protonmail.com we will
protect our sources with our lives and
we are willing to go to jail to protect
them because the truth matters and this
is why you know the the rule of law uh
candidate it m you see that culturally
there's a huge shift we saw this we've
talked about this in the' 60s versus the
70s where everyone was flower and they
said you know we've gone too far we're
too soft on crime then you end up with
dirty hair you end up with dead Death
Wish you end up with vigilante films
because people inherently know uh when
they're being fooled when they're having
the wool pulled over their eyes right
they they know that and now people and
that will dictate their behavior and
that will dictate how they vote you're
seeing it with black Americans you're
seeing it with Latino Americans we gave
you those numbers Biden is only leading
by single digits and you're even seeing
it with Americans under the age of 30 so
they're really really trying hard to
control the flow of information
ironically it's the left doing exactly
what it is that anti-semites accuse the
Jews of doing yeah they're the ones who
are controlling information the media
are there a lot of SE are there a lot of
secular Jews in media and sure but again
these are secular humanists the one
constant is not that everyone is Jewish
in Hollywood or media the one consistent
through line is their leftists they
progressives yeah now let's continue of
course you have these institutions uh
not only media and but intelligencia
college campuses so now Jewish students
have faced incredible hatred since the
October 7th attacks all across I mean
this country and of course even the
world Jewish students standing in the
Cooper Union Library as other students
chant free Palestine outside locked
doors and hold up signs outside the
glass anti-semitic graffiti was found on
American University's campus over the
weekend the school's President says
swastikas and Nazi slogans were found on
two room doors and inside of a bathroom
Corell Professor Russell rickford said
at a rally Turtle Wax that challenged
the Monopoly of
violence and that Terror attacks against
defenseless Jews were exhilarating it
was
exhilarating it was exhilerating it was
energizing made graphic threats against
Jewish students online and urged other
students at Cornell to kill kill them
it's all part of what officials say is a
growing threat to Jewish students in the
wake of the war between Israel and Hamas
and by the way here's something else too
you'll have people out there and I mean
actual anti-semites by the way just to
be clear I think we've been pretty
consistent here you can say no more
money to Israel we should not be
involved and you're not an anti-semite
you think that we shouldn't be involved
in forign Wars I understand that
position I think that morally of course
I support Israel killing them all with
extreme prejudice as it relates to Hamas
but I I don't believe you're an
anti-semite if you are more libertarian
and non-interventionist just to I want
to be really really clear because I
think that that's something people use
and it's a little bit of a red herring
but here's something else people say the
Jews control the media right there you
don't think they have footage of them
saying kill the Jews of course they do
they would rather report on it this is
why we always say hey we want to show
you right we do a claim and usually show
the clip or show the person making the
argument so I don't straw man them we
want to Steelman our political or
ideological opposition that person is
controlling the information by not
showing you what is so shocking but
telling you and if they then decide to
show you a shocking Act of islamophobia
in your mind you'll think oh that's more
severe so that's another sort of slate
of hand that takes place with the media
this happens on college campuses and
it's also been happening outside of the
US the entire Western
world
I'll ask again do you condemn
[Music]
Hamas that's what we would call a layup
yeah mostly peaceful
protestas is not a terrorist group oh it
isn't man first of all Hamas is not a
terrorist
[Music]
group
wow now to be clear that's not all pro
Palestinian uh Advocates out there but
again if there's just a handful of
people saying gas the Jews it's pretty
bad you know let alone the lady with her
a k47 mut dangly earrings well enough
people stayed at the rally and joined in
like you you start here it's like being
at a football game and you see the wave
coming they're like all I guess I'll
participate in this but you don't go you
don't start hearing gas the Jews and
you're like well yeah yeah okay gas the
Jews just think of comparing that to uh
do that think of comparing it to if
someone actually from Mission Control
can bring up the ray EPS situation he's
like we need to go in we need to take
over the fed and people people say fed
fed nah shut up shut up right do those
people the day before January 6th so not
all people but enough and if you
contrast that with 100,000 people
100,000 people at this rally in Paris
protesting anti-Semitism see if you can
spot the
contrast actually
peaceful just murmuring probably
complaining about the weather murmuring
complaining when they're going to have
lunch the at worst as it gets it's
100,000 strong of mildly annoying
people where are there so many people at
the protest
yes so let me ask you this how do you
see this playing out here in the United
States and I want to get to some Global
numbers that I think are important to
constantly revisit uh but first in the
face of all this evidence that these
people know just to be clear I'm a smart
enough guy but I don't assume that I've
figured something out that everybody
else has missed I don't think that
Camala Harris is particularly bright and
I think she's a but nailed I think
that they have enough people around them
who are smart enough to to to to to to
to reach this this conclusion to at
least have these data points kind of
like when Barack Obama would say that
women made 77 cents on the dollar I
believed he had access to Google or Bing
that's just a hunch he knows it's not
true didn't even ask Jes at all he
didn't no she is like web crawled
it so that's a nice reference there
so in the face now of all of this
evidence that I believe no we all know
they have the White House has announced
a plan to combat islamophobia with
another whel task force and so today I
am proud to announce the Biden Harris
Administration will develop our nation's
first national strategy to counter
islamophobia be comprehensive and
detailed plan to protect Muslims and
those perceived to be a Muslim from hate
bigotry and violence and to address the
concern that some government policies
May discriminate against Muslims for
example the so-called Muslim ban which
President Biden revoked on our first day
in office ah Donald Trump's fault I just
want to remind you 55% versus
7.7% yes they just announced the
commission for
7.7% in the midst of the biggest rise in
anti-Semitism that I think we have seen
in our lifetimes yeah right also to be
aware of the travel ban back then right
um we were importing military AED Muslim
males less than 1% with those first
waves Christians I don't know if you
know this why you're talking about
oppressors and oppressed uh over there
under the rule of Isis Christians burned
alive hey in cages why didn't we
proactively bring the people who were
actively murdered and oppressed over
first now when we talk about
islamophobia there's some people who
made some good points you know I've this
is kind of what brought me to the dance
and certainly Gerald like you go back
and listen back when we were on radio or
just on YouTube before this was a Daily
Show or mug Club was a thing um the
Quran challenge was one of the first I
guess sort of viral videos I had done
then we did the Quran challenge too we
would do these rebuttal to talk Islam
who of course supports Hamas now um so
we've been doing this for a very long
time and I grew up in an area of uh
Montreal we had a lot of we had a lot of
Muslims uh at my school uh we had a lot
of Muslims in the city and this is a
place that um you know espouses
multiculturalism not the Melting Pot
Theory so a lot of people don't
necessarily learn the langu
they would come to the province of
Quebec and they would they would
ghettoize and I mean this entirely
Muslim areas uh and and stick with
themselves and so they were I witnessed
growing up probably far more extremism
than you would in the United States
because just like you see in Europe it
was tolerated far more frequently I saw
it at my
school when a guy who came in and wore a
shirt that ihart New York I plane Tower
NY jez this was something that we this
is not a big deal that a kid kids make
stupid decisions but the point is you
wouldn't imagine that happening in a
school here in United States so when
people say islamophobia let me be really
clear
um I am I guess I should say uh afraid
of an ideology that at the very least
can be if you want to say misconstrued
by billions of people on this Earth to
execute anyone who doesn't think like
they do yeah yeah that I think that
that's a that's a fearful for me idea
it's a scary idea scary notion you can
comment below I don't think it's an Ral
fear by the way like I know someone
who's afraid of apples that's irrational
to
me I don't even think that being afraid
of spiders is completely irrational I
get that most of them are non
non-venomous I understand that but the
fact is they're the world's littlest
murderers I mean aside from microbes but
you get my point it's a rational
fear Heights kind of rational because
you die from them when it comes to Islam
we just say islamophobia well let me
give you a number that may say hey this
isn't a phobia
this is a concern based on statistical
reality so we have about 1.8 billion
Muslims across the world 8% of them
believe that
violence against civilians is sometimes
Justified think about that 3% believe
violence is often Justified against
civilians that means that roughly 198
million Muslims support the use of
violence against civilians against
civilians and it's over 50 million on
the lowest end who frequently support
violence against civilians think about
that that's that's multiple times the
size of the population of Canada yeah
which probably not the best example
because they're an inconsequential
Nation pretty silly very inconsequential
it sounded like a big good point to me
what was it it sounded like a good point
yeah I I did my best it's a large
country in Mass you know so 50 something
million believe even if it's just 3%
believe that violence is often Justified
against civilians and 8% believe
sometimes okay so often means you can
pretty much use violence whenever you
want now if you've read the Quran if
you've uh you know if you follow
Muhammad's teachings and you look at
what happens with Islamic governments
this is this is par for the course let's
use that n let's contrast that number
with the global Jewish population is
around 16.1 million so if you were to
say 198 million people believe that
violence against civilians is sometimes
Justified when do you
think Muslims would most justify
violence against civilians maybe when
they're Jewish did you watch far fur did
you see what they were just
showing on television to the children of
Palestine think about that if 100% of
Jews and we can't contrast these numbers
because they don't exist you're not
going to get a poll of American Jews
Jews in uh Jews in Europe asking them
hey how often do you support violence
against civilians the answer would
probably be zero but if 100% of Jews
supported violence against civilians
that would still only be 8% of the 198
million
Muslims islamists however you want to
refer them who support violence against
civilians across the world so if you
want to talk about oppressors and the
oppressed hey how about we go with a
numbers game it's not even close but
let's create another useless task force
for islamophobia you can comment below
you can comment below if you just think
I'm drinking the Kool-Aid and again not
all Muslims not all Jews I've known some
great Muslims here in the United States
who appreciate this country who take a
view of their religion where they've
brought it into the modern world and
I've known some Jews who are at the very
least
annoying but I think the numbers matter
and uh actually we're going to continue
this we're overtime we're really we're
supposed to keep this under an hour
every day 45 to 6 we do like 70 or 80
and we never do Josh is going to be at
Bricktown Comedy Club yes and Tulsa this
Sunday
and uh speaking of all this that's right
Tulsa Tulsa it's not brick it's a weird
name we're going to continue now with
the rest of the uh the gin's kids club
I'm curious to see who they're yeah who
they like Christina agular is their JT I
don't think they have one uh we have a
couple more characters that would not be
allowed here on YouTube they would allow
us on Rumble but this is from mugclub
and we're going to take your chat so if
you're watching on Rumble click that
button right now you get to keep
watching do it uh for another 45 minutes
and it's what keeps all Us Alive we
thank you very much Rumble
YouTube
um I look wait piss
[Applause]
[Music]
off